[Music]
we're both wearing black t-shirts with
very funky designs and we didn't even
send each other a memo to see that no no
mine is from my pal matt in england he
has a a clothing company called hard
times clothing they do not sponsor the
show they don't sponsor me in any way
it's just the pal and he makes really
fun um
clothes usually around kind of uh uh
fan
art
and mine is from a lovely glasgow
company called forty and uh they make
fantastic clothing that i absolutely
love so uh go and get your 40 clothing
they also don't sponsor the show well
they look beautiful amount around your
midriff yeah and and your boobs yeah
around your boobies um how's everything
going with you anything to report this
week
tom you know just you know getting on
with it getting on with that job yeah uh
no things are good
uh
what have you been doing well my friend
and i our friend nigel has been staying
here he and i um jumped in with my
trainer today stevie
and uh my favorite thing to work out is
abs what's your favorite thing to work
out
uh shoulders lovely
so we did a a relatively normal for me
ab heavy
uh workout yeah and i think nigel really
felt the benefit of it because we're all
going out for dinner tonight and i said
tonight if we really pump it up really
pump it up at 10 in the morning then
it's six tonight when we're enjoying
some lovely dinner we'll think well i
can feel the benefit
i'm bulking up how's the bulk going
good we're gonna have to get you a set
of scales right then let's do that hey
remember when we uh we said it was a
what's a good thing to say to someone if
you're pretending you've never seen lord
of the rings before oh yeah and someone
sits you down and says watch this movie
yeah and you say well i've never seen it
what would annoy that person yeah a few
people have sent in with something oh
great
uh dave from barnegat which is in new
jersey says always get gandalf's name
wrong
you either say it dumbledore or
ganondorf oh that's good it's good yeah
people don't like they don't like
getting their names wrong well you
shouldn't be getting gandalf wrong
because would you describe him as the
iconic wizard in uh fantasy fiction
right was it was the one in our first
time
merlin good show maybe marilyn merlin is
a good shout out thanks but i think he's
second mike from chicago said you could
every so often say wait which one is the
mother of dragons which i like which is
a game of thrones reference or you could
say is gollum one of those white walker
guys again confusion
lovely stuff
remember a couple of weeks ago we were
trying to work out fahrenheit and
celsius and centigrade and all that yeah
well adrian location unknown says a
level chemistry teacher taught me this
well i have to stop you for a second
a level chemistry taught me this not a
level chemistry
i was like i wonder what a level
chemistry is
a level is just you've left school and
now you're studying in higher education
you're taking it at a level i would say
adrian location unknown is probably in
the uk then i would agree with that
thank you
celsius is the measure of temperature
centigrade is the type of measurement it
is but people use the two
interchangeably because celsius is the
only
centigrade scale we use day to day i
understand so cell cs
is the
centigrade scale that has become common
practice so nowadays we use both those
words interchangeably gutter nice
um we were also sent a
a tongue twister from
jessie k
in nebraska any uh ideas where nebraska
might be
that took you four girls
you've only got two hands
go on
if this is silly is the wrong way round
hold on florida's on the west coast so
there you go
christ
right
if that was uh a map of the united
states of america yeah florida yeah
new york yeah
california yeah
where would you say is nebraska
that's a hard one actually i think i'm
i'm sure i'm totally way off here but i
got the feeling that nebraska nebraska
was kinda central north yeah nebraska
so i'm gonna say center your hand up a
little bit
to your left
stop
there
we go i think down a little bit that's
more like maine isn't it
i think you go down down down right
right right right right stop i'm going
to say jesus
in just a little bit hold on i'll see if
it's on this map that we've got in the
wall here yeah i'm not sure uh
indiana jessie kale now since jesse case
from omaha
nebraska now when they look at that one
tom because i've got absolutely no idea
what nebraska is okay is that the square
one there's one that's like a square is
it a square state maybe
do you know where nebraska is
she's giving us a shake of the head
there she has no idea no that's terrible
that you should get that in school in
america let us know well jessie k gave
his tongue twister which i feel like
jessie k might have written himself
maybe who knows and the tongue twister
is how many lows could rob lowe rob if
rob lowe could rob lowe's
i'm gonna tame you if you do that three
times though
i'll do the same you ready yeah three
two one go how many lows could rob lowe
rob if rob lowe could rob lowe's how
many lows could rob lowe rob if rob lowe
could rob lowe's how many lows could rob
lowe rob if rob lowe could rub lows that
was actually very good
8.78 seconds keep that there don't
delete it i want i'm gonna give you a
three two one and but i'm also gonna
give you a go like you did
ready yeah
three two one go how many lows could rob
blow rob if rob loop no
it's all right you got three goes it's
quite hard because i'm scottish in ours
are quite hard and then please
ours after elves are even harder take
your time william blood right
ready
three two one go how many lows could rob
lou rob if rob lowe could rob lowe's how
many lows could rob lou rob if rob lowe
could rob lose how many lose could rob
lou rob if rob though could rob lose
lovely you slightly changed your accent
as well to help me out it's a 12.13 i
thought it was slow it was a little slow
it felt slow but for a scotsman i'm
extremely impressed with all the things
that was quite hard for me that one time
hey we have one more thing that was
written in from owen in brighton do you
want to um read this one out oh yeah
regarding the word possesses oh you said
this didn't you recently you claimed
that the word possesses possesses more
esse than any other word possesses
however i believe that the word
dispossesses dispossesses the word
possesses claim to
possess more essies than any other word
possesses i think that's totally true
dispossesses there's more s's than uh
possessors how did we not know that i
don't know but that particular phrase
came from willian friedkin
the
director of
the exorcist because i think he'd spent
a lot of time in his life around the
word possesses because of course the
exodus is about possession and someone
must have come over to him and said are
you aware that possesses possesses more
s's than any other word possesses but of
course dispossesses because uh possesses
one more so this possesses actually
dispossesses the word possesses yeah
that's what owen in brighton was saying
thanks zoey from brighton
william what you and i both seem to
enjoy really pumping up at the gym i
hear you dom let me tell you one of my
favorite things to do both before and
after the gym is i have a lovely bowl of
magic spoon cereal now you might be
thinking cereal that's not great for the
gym hey well magic spoon's full of
proteins there's no sugar it's a gym
conscious food item and i absolutely
love it and i tell you what there's a
flavor for everyone from the richest
chocolate to
the sweetest honey nut and it's
delicious dumb ice cold milk all over it
fantastic there's a few facts that i
have to give you dom go on there is zero
grams of sugar what 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four to five neck grams
of carbs in every serving amazing it's
low carb dom keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free and only
140 calories a serving is fantastic
great flavors as you know cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter cookies cream
cinnamon all of it it's delicious it's
delicious yeah fill your boots go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and try the magic for yourself
and be sure to use the promo code onion
at the checkout to save five dollars off
your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's back
with 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions ass
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com and use the code onion to
save five dollars off
we've got voicemails done let's do them
let's do a couple of voices
hi billy and dom i've got a riddle for
you here's how it goes this is a five
letter word with all five letters people
can eat it
however if you remove the first letter
then i become a form of energy
if you remove another letter then i am
required to live
if you mix up the final three letters
then i am a drink what word am i
love the show and all the lord of the
rings movies have a great day guys
right so
five players five letters each letter is
something you can eat so i'm gonna say p
right
t but you take away one
yeah it becomes what an energy an energy
but don't we need to
do it in order or not to guess it or not
necessarily i don't think so so it's a
five-letter word right so let's i'm
gonna think of letters that you can eat
so p i think it's gotta be that way can
you be
you could eat a b but would you either b
no c d e
e
f g h i
j k
no
special k oh it could be special k k l m
n
o
p i wouldn't eat p
no i didn't like a green marathon oh
right i said you meant like urine yeah
no no q r s t
you can eat you can drink drink yeah
u v
w x y zed there's only two real things
that you could eat there could dad get
that again
again he written down all the clues
shown to you hey give us that again
shanti come on
hi billy and dom i've got a riddle for
you here's how it goes this is a five
letter word with all five letters people
can eat it
however if you remove the first letter
then i become a form of energy if you
remove another letter then i am required
to live
if you mix up the final three letters
then i am a drink what word am i it's
only when it's the first time
you can eat it when it's four it's
energy energy when
you need air to live uh-huh that's a
three-letter word a bear
you need a canadian bear
oh yeah well type of energy
a what is four letters
well that kind of takes away from air
doesn't it it does
a type of energy
wind that's four layers
uh solar that's five
and then if you is it you mix up the
last three what is it shanty if you mix
up the last three t drink it t right so
let's say it was t right but i said
mixed up so that's so it's eight so if
it's tea
and then what's the what's the full a
type of power
type of energy
heat
heat heat
we we're on to it and then sheet
what was the first one heat er it's uh
you can eat it cheap feet beat no that's
not speed right but wheat wheat wait
have i done it
nice we've got there fantastic wheat
heat eat eat
shanty was actually helping us john
would never help
shannon just gave us a thumbs up but we
had together but she was like screaming
and going yeah yeah we've done it
brilliant thanks shanti brilliant firing
another voicemail into our uh craniums
which yeah let's get in our voicemail
and then i think we have to get on to it
my name is haley and i am a current
student of biology
and as a horror movie lover and an
insect lover i am fascinated by
parasitoid insects
um
so my question for you is what is your
favorite scary insect or in other words
what insect freaks you out or scares you
the most
for me i'll give an example it would be
a parasitoid wasp and if you have ever
seen a caterpillar infected with
parasitoids it's it's pretty interesting
um yeah uh thank you bye
have you seen that william is that when
they lay their their their
eggs and then they hatch and then it
just destroys the
i'm glad nothing does that to us to us
it would be terrifying yeah so the
parasitoid wasp
paralyzes the caterpillar for half an
hour or so lays let's say for the sake
of argument 10 eggs in there but it
could be 20 or 30. and then the
caterpillar wakes up and thinks fine i'm
all right and then at some point
they all just explode out of the
caterpillar
that's a rough one
i think
kind of
leeches
but they're not technically an insect
it's an invertebrate but
leeches have always kind of
given me the heaps and i did get
did get leeches on me when i was in
vietnam going through a lake and
this is interesting i woke up in the
middle of the night and felt something
on my back yeah
it was elites just a slimy like kind of
leech and i managed to grab it
and throw it uh to the other side of the
bedroom no electricity on in this place
so i just thought i'll throw as far away
as i can and deal with that in the
morning and then in the middle of the
night i heard a commotion and i grabbed
my torch
and i looked in my room there's a big
tokai gecko these huge geckos that you
get in uh in vietnam in that part of the
world that can give you a good bite if
you're a human was attacking this leech
and clearly the leech was fighting back
and there was blood my blood i think and
the leeches all sprayed up the side of
the wall and i thought at that point
that i had peed the bed but i hadn't
because the leech's bite contains an
anticoagulant and my bed had blood all
over it because i had consistently bled
throughout the night
i know that's a horror story i know and
that's well she's talking about horror
films and that's always given me a
little bit of a thing with with leeches
not strictly an insect but no what about
you tell me again
what makes an insect an insect an insect
is defined by having six legs and having
a head a middle part which is called a
thorax and an abdomen right so a
butterfly is an insect but they're lava
the caterpillar isn't no an insect
because it it doesn't have a head thorax
an engine it's just one long piece right
yeah i think well
parasites are the worst day
things that sort of live in you and
around you you know that book that you
got me the body that i'm still ready
well there's a part in that where it
talks about actually you know whatever
weight you are like more than half of
that isn't actually you
it's just things living in you and on
you incredible
manner amazing
tape worms a little scary again not an
insect but go on yeah
so anything that kind of
lays something in you you know they
always say things will go in your ear
and lay things in is that happened
in africa my producing partner dave
brady who you met because you came to do
an amazing version of wild things in new
zealand he got a bot fly
in his batok
and when he went back to see his doctor
in uh canada the guy said take a
piece of bacon
and put a tiny piece of bacon underneath
a plaster a band-aid yeah and let the
bot flat come out and then once it rears
its head up have your wife grab it with
tweezers and pull it out and he said
yeah it was massive like as big as a
gummy bear when he pulled it out
in his bottom imagine gummy bears did
that
burrowed their way into your butt
you wouldn't buy them would you there's
a great quote from david attenborough
and you know however way you feel about
theology and religion and all that kind
of stuff
you're in your own kind of
personal
freedoms and everything but someone had
said to andrew how come
as someone who spent your entire life
examining nature
do you not see god in these things do
you not see god in in the patterns of a
giraffe's skin or do you not see god in
the teeth of a tiger and all that kind
of stuff and attenborough's rebuttal to
that said that's fair enough maybe you
can see god in those things but if
that's the case then you also need to
see god in the borrowing
parasite that goes into a human's eye
and the maggot will eat out the eye on
its way out to becoming a fly so if you
see god in this yeah
also to touch very briefly on parasites
for a second the mosquito being you know
one of one of the most interesting
parasites for human history because it's
probably the most influential animal in
human history killed more humans than
all the
all the wars combined
that mosquito
has a parasite that lives in its body
which is the parasite that gives us
these very dangerous diseases that kill
us the female mosquito just sucks our
blood to make eggs for its young and
that's it unfortunately when it drinks
out of stagnant water a parasite goes up
its mouth parts lives in its body and
uses the mosquito as a parasite a
carrier to send malaria into other
people's bodies so of course mosquitoes
get a bad rap but the mosquito has no
idea that it is holding on to malaria
and probably doesn't want to if you were
to be in a place to be able to ask that
mosquito it has a parasite itself and
that parasite has malaria that parasite
is malaria
as malaria
lives in stagnant water
and can a mosquito get malaria no i
don't think it can it just holds on to
it for bigger animals
so the mosquito is a
involuntary
uh carrier of malaria in the same way
that rats were because rats carried
fleas that had the plague it wasn't the
rats that had the plague it was the
fleas that carried them and that's some
of the fantastic knowledge you'll get
here on the friendship onion wait you
didn't say your favorite parasitic uh
insect i don't know their names any of
them oh but there's nothing in sticker
that stands out that makes you go
no just anything it's sort of remember
when we were in um uh
thailand of course i do and we met a guy
and he had a thing living in his leg
he'd been there for months and he says
it moves around and he says before it
moves
he feels where it's going to go and then
it
makes a wait and he knows where it's
going to go how does he like something i
don't want something living in me no i'd
rather not but like you said in terms of
the butt that you're reading when you
get into the digestive system you and i
oh yeah probably have a whole bunch of
parasites living in our digestive system
peacefully if i don't know they're there
i'm all right but i don't want it kind
of moving around my leg and stuff of
course you don't wear them of course you
do should we get our guests on let's
bring on our fantastic guests this week
sean and cj um who have
a wonderful podcast which is in week
three so it's just beginning you can
check it out it's called the blackout
diaries sean unfortunately is in chicago
so he's gonna be remote but cj's here
let's bring him on let's bring him on
william we're here we're joined by sean
and cj can i can i please read shawn's
blurb and you read cj's blurb that
sounds fantastic let's do that tomorrow
right this is all about sean blair
flannery who's not in the studio with us
is on the tv
chicago which i believe is the east
coast of the united states
there we go the easiest way to describe
sean flannery is
colon
he attended the wrong wedding twice
interesting we're going to get into that
in a second okay that mostly sums it up
sean houston created the blackout
diaries he appeared on comedy central
npr serious radio and his debut book
places i can't return to interesting
title was just released sean was also
named best drunk by the chicago reader
he and his wife are having different
reactions to that award fantastic bit
strong that's fantastic
let's hear about cj please right cj
sullivan resides in los angeles and
previously called chicago his home for
many years cj has been on comedy
essential and performs in numerous
comedy clubs across the country his
writing credentials include projects for
a e network comedy central robert
smeagle and xml serious radios sullivan
also a world series of poker winner
professional poker player
garnered the number one comedy album
spot on itunes for his newly released
stand-up comedy album called what am i
complaining about everybody should go
out and get that right now
he was chosen as one of the top 12
rising stars to look out for top 12.
that's like he never made the top ten so
they just stuck another couple on it
and by chicago magazine and he won the
comics choice award for best comic in
chicago during the pandemic lockdown cj
performed on his balcony and nightly
showbiz for all the applause intended
for frontline work yeah wonderful stuff
hey a significantly more fantastic
substantial introduction to cj than to
sean well that's because cj took the
time to come into the studio to talk to
us and sean couldn't be asked and stayed
in chicago that seems to be the case
well gentlemen welcome thank you
i love when you guys say the uh correct
or incorrect states of america i was
listening to last week's episode uh the
enthusiasm yeah you know
of the uh state of the different states
like chicago the windy apple or whatever
yeah i mean
we never quite get it right because you
know there's 50 and then within those 50
there's all the different cities it's
quite a lot to learn absolutely when you
didn't get it at school you know i'll
learn about european history so i'm
learning every day yeah
i'm saying i love the uh well it's
something that we do as well even if you
don't know say it with enthusiasm
together so like it matters like it's
like it is correct and it comes
exactly i'm like yeah new york is in
massachusetts why not well guys lovely
to have you both on now do you guys when
you when you guys do your podcast you're
doing it together right yeah do you do
it in the same room not always um yeah
we're not usually not in the same city
but
kind of situation yeah i'm usually in
chicago he's usually
cj travels more than i do so but we
usually once a week we find a time
it's almost like a couple in therapy we
find a time
and uh we record together and you and
your podcast is called the blackout
diaries which deals with moments in
which uh people become blackout drunk is
that right well yeah it's kind of just
more of a night you know it got away
from you kind of the story and it's not
like a negative thing and uh
yeah and we have stand-up comics plus we
have like everyday people on the show so
like in chicago it's been a live show in
chicago for over 10 years and we'll have
like cops and teachers and nurses tell
drinking stories right right and the
shawn says when you black out the
science behind it actually is that your
your brain just decides to stop
recording the events of what's going on
you're aware you know what the brain's
like yeah you're not gonna have to
remember this but that's where we come
in
film the rest of the footage really i
guess
blackout part and uh dictate the story
of what happens between two and four so
bl the blackout diaries was started by
sean but cj you've had enough blackouts
that you thought you'd be someone who
could go though i just stumbled upon it
in a blackout and he just signed me up
apparently you know i'm here in the
studio brilliant and is that a weekly
podcast yes it is
is it one of these ones that people can
get wherever they get podcasts yeah
we're having a podcast star burns audio
is putting it out there but it's you
know we're all pods are told you know
apple and google right podfather
whatever they're called you know but uh
it's every tuesday third episode just
came out today and as you see it's just
when knights get away and they become
something strange yeah because you've
drunk too much absolutely i love it yeah
it's kind of like
there's a couple slogans we're going
with it's like a reverse aaa meeting
or if it's kind of i don't know it's
kind of like the best story you know a
cocktail party i guess it's a good story
great stories usually audio visual and
as sean said what stands it apart is
like there's also besides comics it's
also regular people that contribute to
society you know like
normal normal jobs and good people and
they have but they have the best stories
you know yeah
lots of people unfortunately have
moments where they've had one or two
drinks too many and found themselves a
little uh
kind of
forgetful in the morning of certain
stints of time right
yeah like you said
i very often remember we'll remember the
start and possibly the end and then
there's bits in between that you think
well how did i get from that bar to my
house
that's when you come in billy yeah yeah
i'll let you know hey sean so how come
what's this about you went to the wrong
way and twice yeah was it your
uh it was not my wedding
thankfully that's good um i've never
been a details man and the thing you got
to keep in mind i'm i don't know if this
is uh true where you guys grew up but in
america
wedding invitations have highly stilted
almost archaic language okay you know
it'll be like you know the parent and
they use like everyone's legal names and
i don't even know my buddies legal names
so like i just find them i kind of just
find them confusing and i just sort of
like bottom line it and i'm like oh okay
it's i just assume they're always in
cleveland because that's where i'm from
right so i once flew back to cleveland
and uh
right before the wedding i found out it
was actually in kentucky and that i had
not read the invitation properly
so you didn't go to that one but you're
dressed for a wedding and you would you
know i'm still going to a wedding so you
had the you had the actual address but
you just missed out the you the kentucky
part so you saw like 114 springfield
road or something i found out i
was like what church is this i've never
heard of this church i called somebody
who was in the wedding
and they're like well it's right
downtown and i'm like where and they're
by the river i'm like there's no river
downtown
and then that's when i found out it was
in lexington kentucky and i was in the
wrong state
what did you do did you just go out for
a little night yourself i i did i had a
date with me i remember the person i was
talking to laughing at the top of my her
lungs when she found out i had a date
with me that i was now going to have to
explain like we're in the wrong state
well yeah we just went out we had a
great time honestly you know to be
honest with you the only disadvantage to
flying to the wrong state for a wedding
is that every wedding you go to for the
rest of your life when you show up like
your cousins and your friends all make a
like hey you're in the right state like
they all make a big production about the
fact that you actually made it to the
right state right yeah you gave a
material what about the time though when
you entered the wedding and you you gave
the gift to the couple like they put in
the gift box well so that one i was in
the right state for that one but the
wrong wedding all right so it was one of
those uh venues
where they have multiple weddings it's
like a big hotel they have multiple
weddings going on at the same time and i
only knew the wedding party so i walk in
and the wedding party's still doing
photographs i'm like oh okay they're not
back yet and i put my gift in the gift
box
and uh the wedding party comes in like a
half hour later i'm at the bar and i see
like oh my god i'm at the wrong wedding
again like i don't recognize any of
these people
and he wonders why they're introducing
hey you made the right wedding this time
well it's a constant thing with you
so i had to get the the wedding planner
to get my gift out because you know i i
was like well i can't go to the real
wedding without my gift that's brilliant
you know dom once uh we were in uh l.a
before i lived here and he had friends
who were having a fancy dress party
and he said but you know you want to
come along
and i said yeah yeah
what will we go as they said well let's
go as a sort of couple you know a famous
something and we came up with a batman
and robin goes batman he said would you
want to be i said why would i be batman
all right
so i got batman he's got the robin we
went to a bar first and oh everybody's
laughing and joking weird batman and
robin we went to the party
it was fancy dress but it was uh
what did they call it it was classical
prom attire prom it was a promata
a fancy dress so everybody's all dressed
as prom and we're batman and robin yeah
he's a good it was a good night yeah he
should have won a spider man
she was high school level right
i knew it was classic prom attire oh did
you really
yeah but i kept that from billy because
i knew that if i said to billy it's
classic promise but i want to go as
batman robin billy no well let's do that
it was very funny we went to the
standard hotel beforehand
we got invited at the the standard hotel
someone said they were making a
pornography movie that's right really
and they asked us if we wanted to be
involved without knowing that absolutely
that's just a check-in because they have
the they have the woman behind the desks
there you know and yeah behind the wall
behind the glass
man he could have been batman
so you guys said
yes we just kept the mass on that's all
right he had a free breakfast with it
well there's a lot going on here there's
a lot to unpack um sean you've also got
a book
places i can't return to is this
associated with uh being inebriated
uh some of it is some of it are some of
them are just places that are gone you
know like that don't exist anymore so
it's just a collection of funny stories
some are drinking stories some are like
old family stories you know it's a
summer jobs that i got fired from had
nothing to do with drinking you know so
just different places that have asked me
not to return for one reason or another
the answer is yes i've read the i've
read the book and i've been i've known
it for years they're all somehow related
to drinking
jobs you got fired from yes
interview from a days beforehand of of
an absolute bender what's what's you
guys is tipple normally
well
or are you not fussy sean likes to bring
nothing yes
sean brings his own customs to the bars
he likes to um bring a briefcase as i
said as he says which is his own to not
pay for a tab you know so he'll bring
his own um oh doesn't he yeah yeah
because it's like
yeah it was a little kind of a wet bar
because he has a certain drinking budget
his wife gave him and then so to keep
under it he has a briefcase and he'll
like have an assortment of different
drinks that he knows each bar serves and
no
in a suit like at midnight acting like
he's doing business with japan like
doing a business call like it was
briefcase and he opens up and he's got a
full wet bar in there you can save a lot
of money that way yeah
so then in that case you you're showing
you'll order like a club soda or a or a
tonic water but then you'll bring your
own gin is that the idea sort of what
i'll usually do is um when i'm doing
that is i'll order a gin and tonic
and then i'll just kind of refill it
myself throughout the night so i i
usually you know it's a little
suspicious if you're just all of a
sudden acting completely rowdy and you
haven't ordered a single drink yeah from
the bottom so i usually order a couple
drinks from the bottom like that but
yeah
so
not picky
what we're trying to say if you if you
own a bar in chicago and you see sean
coming in please know that in his bag
he'll have his own bottle of gym yeah so
i would say search that bag if you would
yeah just going back to europe we didn't
get cj's there too all right that's
right does this do that no no no i i
think that covers it all i'm actually
well so you're not fussy you'll anything
right yeah okay sure i was just going to
say i just remember the story there uh
talking about your your wedding story
there sean the um my wife's
uh dad
uh i don't know if it's the same over
here but if you live in a city like uh
chicago or los angeles but where we are
in glasgow there's a obituary page where
if you if you die
then your family puts a little thing in
saying you know
uh you don monohan is dead
and uh he died peacefully well that's
absolutely well it's all so dumb and uh
the funeral is going to be at this place
at that time you know and as you get
older in scotland you you read this page
because you know your friends are some
of them are catching even you know what
i mean right catch up in your old bodies
so he's he's reading it and oh elizabeth
elizabeth gordon elizabeth gordon's died
oh and he sent me his wife and and said
oh the funeral's on on thursday i'll go
along
so he gets his suit on and all and he
goes off to the funeral and
he's saying hello to everybody in that
and they have the funeral and they go
back afterwards oh please come back
we're going to have steak pie and a
drink
and it has a steak pie and a drink and
all that
and says goodbye elizabeth gordon
and then a couple of weeks later he's
he's in he's in the local store like you
know the local vaughn's kind of
supermarket and there's elizabeth gordon
walking up this
and he says elizabeth and she said
he says how is that looks at your
funeral
and it was another elizabeth gordon
he went he went
so he went through it anyway he went to
the whole thing yeah said hello had
spent the whole day with him
went
to someone he'd never ever met right but
something left maybe that's why the
catholics uh started doing open caskets
just to avoid this
and funerals are some of the best times
fantastic
well do you guys also do stand up
there's a bit of um cj does he's all
over the he's all over the place
that's right yeah how does that go it
goes i go maul them all across this
country and uh do the jokes how awesome
is it like how much do you do i know
it's true well it depends obviously
whenever whatever's uh
i was in a mall in ontario california
last weekend which is about an hour
outside the city
yeah you know but now i've moved up to
the great mall of america next weekend
in minnesota i'll get lost in that mall
and then what time's the show well like
the food court closes at seven and then
the show's at uh 7 30 right afterwards
well
nine type things yeah yeah of course
it's okay yeah it's a really you you're
being honest i well the club's in the
mall it's not in the mall like it's not
like i'm in the food court so there's a
spencer there's a club and the mall oh
yeah we're attaching them all that's all
that's all there is to small you got to
understand this mall is like bigger than
an airport it's not like your normal
vision of the cg explains there's an
airport inside this mall that's how big
this mall is it's very much of america
yeah no there is there's like a roller
coaster in it and all kinds of shootings
and then we've got coleman and then of
course comedy i think there might be two
clubs in it actually it's so big that's
crazy and then see when you go out to do
these stand-ups do you like are you
going for like a month
or do you just
in and out yeah usually i'll co-wrote to
the weekend and come back or whatever
but sometimes if it's like
towns or close to each other i'll go out
there for a couple weeks couple months
or whatever i'm not like
on a tour bus or anything like that like
yeah but um yeah you go out there and
you see you see this beautiful country
and uh
all the real people where kova didn't
hit what's what's been the most
effective way thus far for you to uh
deal with hecklers
deal with hacklers what's the most
effective way you're like wow that is
the best way to do it oh well it's it's
not it's not hard to deal with hecklers
you're they're usually just uh usually
drunk yeah they're very drunk and uh
they don't have a microphone what i do
you don't tell them you're from los
angeles that's for sure i would rather
they were you know
yeah they just can't handle it they
can't handle it they don't they don't
like they don't like they don't like the
the words they like hearing about it you
know so right i just go is it kind of
like how the other half lives yeah yeah
it's just i don't know it's just what
they're told about ella you know either
it's like it's just it's just enrages
them it's making some language yeah it
really does yeah yeah
how how did you guys meet you and sean
in chicago we came up doing comedy
together in chicago oh really yeah
absolutely
um for a year yeah years ago tons of fun
you don't do as much of that now sean
uh i do um but i'm mostly you know i
have three kids and i have two weekly
shows here in chicago so i don't travel
as much as cj he was part of the other
people i was saying that contribute to
society you know he has a family right
jobs and things like that but yeah he
runs the blackout diaries live show at
the lincoln lodge in front yeah so we're
like the blackout diaries uh is a live
show every single friday here in chicago
and then i also have a weekly show on
wednesday so i'm i don't travel as much
as cj but i i'm usually performing you
know most nights right but it seems like
a different venue each night because
he's different because he's drunk you
know so every time he's a different
audience in the family it's like blacked
out yeah absolutely so
the blackout diaries on a friday night
are you bringing people up from the
audience after slightly vetting them to
have them tell their story of blackout
adventures you know we when we first
started we would let people just get up
and um tell a story and
that lasts at about three people before
we're like okay we can never do this
again
you know like i think one of the last
people we let do that i i honestly was
like i feel like i have to call the
police after what this man just said so
we usually
we invite people to tell stories but
they have to pitch it to us in advance
and then we have to like make sure it's
like appropriate right to stay in front
of a room full of people and it's one of
those uh one of sean's talents is that
he'll be out there doing doing it
they're doing the legwork during the uh
during the off night show nights and
like oh i got a perfect guy for i got a
perfect guy for the blackout diaries
that's usually
haunting words like oh [ __ ] who did you
meet you know and it was like you know
some some
something he's a male man but he used to
work for the cia he claims
you know one of those things they meet a
lot of great liars in chicago and like
yeah like they claim which one i used to
have these weird jobs yeah we're not
against the virus they're usually very
entertaining yeah i love blatant liars
i'm sure it makes for a great show and
you're also a professional poker player
well i got to update that at bio a
little bit but absolutely
i used to yeah for sure absolutely i
haven't i still play a little bit but
not as uh certainly you can't you can't
dedicate your uh
you have to dedicate you can't dedicate
half your time to poker or half your
time to comedy or half your time to
blacken out really you gotta focus on
that's gonna be a fit yeah you gotta uh
right exactly that's why i'm blacked out
or math class you can't or the other
half of you're right right
where i would add that up but um yes no
i i did win a circuit event i used to be
um
pretty much into it now it's then
then i was like yeah i don't think i
want to hang around these people the
rest of my life you know like these uh
card players you meet a lot of great
characters but also like i don't know if
there's a way to
to go about so now i'm
on the road doing blackout shows so
they're kind of
can you make generalized negative
connotations towards professional poker
players
sure i can make a negative connotation
towards anyone if you give me a give me
a chance
what's the deal with the professional
poker circuit that's not great well you
know it's just like uh
it's again did you degenerate is a uh
it's a fun word
to say of course yeah it is a fun
see uh characters but like it's like uh
i don't know it's kind of like how how
rats they don't really attack each other
but they will they have to survive
kind of a world like um i don't know
it's a lot of monster energy drinks and
hoodies yeah you know
sunglasses indoors and kind of you know
just those situations and like uh sweats
the hygienes a lot a lot of up hours and
uh you know it's just a lot of
felt and
stale cigarettes did you have do you
ever play with jennifer tilly no i have
not she completely she's she's great
she's good absolutely yeah love jennifer
she's the best she was on craig ferguson
one night and i got a chance to say
hello to him
possibly the sweetest voice of all time
as well and he's very very good at polka
really yeah
yep she's really good and she was
actually in a great that great gambling
movie let it ride with uh
i can't keep up treyface so
texas holding was the game that you were
playing right back then yeah that's like
the
the flop and the river right and
everyone got good at it and jennifer and
jennifer tilly's whooping everyone's ass
you know like it's time to get out of
this trying to get out of this game toby
maguire i suppose yeah they used to run
a game ben him and leo did you see
molly's game of course yeah nice movie
right it was very good very well written
yeah and um some interesting characters
in there some based on real life
absolutely yeah she took over that game
apparently that was like the thing that
i think
that was toby mcguire and leo's game and
then she like took it over so yeah yeah
that would have been nice because
because actors are usually the worst
poker players because they're so
animated with their expressions in their
face so when they they try to act like
they're bluffing to go
really like you know yeah yeah
yeah that's not how you uh lie in real
life
they know how to lie in acting life you
know which is
very obvious sean what made you uh get
um
well win
best drunk in the uh
great city of chicago what did you do
did you fall in front of a moving boss
or something
so you know it's interesting that you
bring that up and it's interesting the
way different people have interpreted
that so that was by the chicago reader
and they wanted to do this novelty thing
then they they thought the end of year
awards were becoming boring and rather
than say somebody's the best comic
or even the best car wash
in chicago they came up with these like
little esoteric awards to say it in so
many words so rather than calling me the
best comic in chicago they call me the
best drunk like when that first happened
that was uh several years ago like i
would be almost it's almost like uh when
you're like a heavyweight champion and
like i've heard that people want to
fight them yeah like when they go to
bars yeah like i was confronted over
that people would be like
oh you know you think you're the best
drunk in chicago well i've ruined three
marriages you know i've totaled five
cars i'm a much you know
and well then you're like well i don't
know that that doesn't mean you're a
better yeah
sounds like a horrible drunk yeah that's
true actually you should be
in prison yeah i think you'd be a
happy-go-lucky drunk he really is a
great uh positive drunk
for sure i am what do you guys think
about yeah history did you guys yeah of
course yeah i think it's great a lot of
people are doing that it's a picture too
what's the name of the guy who kind of
started it the guy who's stars in it
quite a bit oh ben franklin i believe it
goes
good knowledge good knowledge i'll see
you well done thank you what's your
favorite joke
i don't care
you're here for the tough questions do
you want to hear me i do because i know
that that's exactly why you have sex
exactly only what i just heard i only
watched
well i was gonna say i just heard a
great irish joke and i wish i could do
an irish accent i can't um but this was
told to me uh from a friend who was
visiting from ireland please do the
accent anyway yeah do it
i know i
but yeah so the one guy is at the end of
the the pub
and he's like where are you from and
he's like i'm from uh county court he
said get out of here i'm from county
cork
he's like wait where wearing county cork
he's like
oh i'm from tremont street get out of
here i'm from tremont street like what
what's your address and he's like oh i'm
five two three minutes like get out of
here i'm five two tremont he's like
which of the which of the levels were
you basement level get out of here i'm
basement level
and then the bartender turns to a a
visitor who just came in and goes well
the mcginty twins are at it again
now that was a great irish accent i
don't know what you're talking about
that was amazing absolutely nailed it
that's that's it let's hear it come on
right right this is tough it's in the
scottish action scottish accent again
all right i'll do this i'll do the
accent shot and i'll do it all right
he's out
he's got experience with him he's not
afraid
when i was younger
i had the trumpet tree and my garden
but a man from the council came and
rooted
on john that is an accent heavy joke
very localized
i want to see sean try that on friday at
his club
yeah that
[Laughter]
right
since we're all here with a background
of the blackout diary should we eat
stroke drink the world yes because then
we can really do a deep dive into this
because i think this has been one of the
more
anticipated you have been really wanting
to try this because people have told you
it's so awful uh having a heaven we were
gifted uh some bottles of this thing
which we'll bring in in a second i would
say about two or three months ago and
when we recently went to a convention in
chicago a bunch of people said to both
billy and i you have to try this thing
it's absolutely disgusting
that's the perfect tagline for it you
have to try it it's awesome it's awful
yeah i'm pretty sure you're talking
about our corporate sponsor yeah that's
exactly exactly what they're talking
about and it's coming out
how do you pronounce it my lord
let us all try my lot
and we'll try it in the style of cj for
sure yes root two two let's get it go
are you ready to do so every week we try
and ask our guests to bring something
that they either have a an affinity with
or something they can grow up with or
something closely or so it's associated
with themselves or their city this feels
perfect
chicago is something that you guys do as
a joke to drink now or will you to be
honest with you yeah it's a it's kind of
a chicago tradition it's horrible and
you always get outsiders to do it like
you got to try it and then they never
just to see the pain in her face it's
kind of like an initiation going to
chicago but right it it does taste it it
kicks me better hits better when it's
like minus five degrees outside oh when
it's cold i put my spectrum billy you
didn't remind me to put my specs for
your spectrum well i read out this
little bit here
is a hairball licker whose flavor has
been described as everything from
fermented grapefruit
to bunk carpet
or even nail polish remover people love
it or they hate it it's usually i hate
it but in chicago they keep drinking it
all the same uh
we even have a malot hot sauce that's
right come on let's try it where is it
well while it's coming in shanty's
bringing it in just to try and explore
this um
hornet's nest with our american guests
the word herbal
you pronounce as
herbal right
at one point was that herbal when was
the h dropped when's the good question
jamaican
because there is an egg
i i hear both i feel oh really yeah yeah
for sure is it certain possible
is probably more common but i feel like
you heard hear both herbal
cj maybe you could tell us why
has just
landed as a boiled egg and a fork the
food is a hard-boiled egg oh my god but
why as it's known as a boneless chicken
dinner residence advertised um we used
to uh
one of the great that me and sean ollie
do we come up with uh comedy together we
used to do a uh
uh internet radio show before it was
even called podcast called a business
locker room it was called the visitors
locker room it's kind of a uh sports
comedy thing it's a sports show yeah
it's very
well not even to talk about but we would
go to a bar right this grape dive bar in
chicago called richards right when it's
an amazing bar and they would um kind of
bar where you would you could still
smoke inside you still do it now it's
like not like legal actually one time we
saw a girl complain about the smoke and
they kicked her out oh
absolutely and they would serve and they
would serve these boneless chicken
dinners that's how they would advertise
it was the only food they would have
what would that be just bald eggs
so that would be all right that's not
pickled absolutely not
um
now you guys they were weirdly cheap i
think they were like seventy-five cents
like 2015. oh yes it's an egg it's a
chicken egg well that's quite good
there's a bar next to where i live and
they give you free hot dogs really yeah
i don't know how long those guys have
been in there
you know i mean it's like boiled hot
dogs
sitting there one of my favorite
traditions about spain where my brother
and my parents live is is obviously the
tapas thing and i remember asking my dad
oh god don't billy
turn in my stomach i remember asking my
mom and dad about that a while ago and
in the south of spain
supposedly the idea is
you get your drink let's say your little
glass of beer or your glass of wine and
they'll put maybe some olives or a
little bit of bread something like that
yeah on a saucer and that saucer will
stop something going in your drink or
stop someone from coming along and
feeling like maybe that drink has been
finished you put your little sauce on
there so the tapas thing in that part of
spain supposedly was created to stop
maybe flying insects getting used but
also
somehow the egg made the malort worse
and the lord made the egg worse
my mum was here
she would have walked ah that is
fantastic
i might have invented something here
my mom i think i get my my slight uh
trepidation with eggs from my mum but my
mum could not be around people eating
eggs i was at lax months ago and a
couple sat down at the gate that i was
uh flying from as well and they opened
up a little tupperware box and started
eating boiled eggs and they cleared out
the gate right the gate just stood up
and walked off and they didn't they did
not give a rat's ass at all i like a
boiled egg yeah
i don't know
i don't know how i've never heard such a
i don't know how much she's doing
i'm a bit weird he he won't eat eggs
that someone else has cooked any eggs
any style there's definitely not anyone
else's cook maybe my parents or people
that i love i've eaten billy's eggs
before but i have to trust them you know
so if you're at a diner you'll you'll
you'll have to go behind the counter go
ahead
pick
hey i'll continue on billy about
jefferson's mallory for a second
jackson's milo
it's chicago's version of
brisk
brandon
is that wait a minute that sounds
sweetie stomp hang on it's a swedish
style schnapps distilled with the
flavour of wormwood which is not good
the word itself is actually just swedish
word for wormwood that's right
wormwood the drink was first used as a
medicine in the middle ages much later
malor made its way to chicago by way of
one particular swedish immigrant
carl gibson
are we going to try this my law well
maynar's got an egg in it dumb oh god
i'm gonna stop drinking eggy melon yeah
yeah
william you're disgraceful yes it will
not make it taste worse it will not
taste worse no i think it will happen we
definitely need a name for what you just
invented
you've come up the first thing that
comes out of your mouth after you do
that will be what this invention you
call it and then do you know
three or four years from now when we go
to bars in chicago everybody's drinking
these guys
yes
let's all have a billy boyd all right
i'm gonna try this
um sean you've not got him a lot no
you're just watching yeah i'm sorry i
didn't know we were uh
but
i do the old oh it's just pure alcohol
isn't it
yeah it's actually not as high in
alcohol content as you would think
that's one of the reasons why people
like to shoot it because there's
actually a low alcohol
very bitter
well then give it a good very bitter and
it's going to get more bitter as the
aftertaste grows it's one of the few
drinks that gets worse with time
he likes it no i don't think he does i
do like him no i could tell i know
you could tell when he likes it when
someone fake likes it too but you know
you could tell them
yeah i don't know what i did one one out
of twenty it'll catch you like that and
next you know not for me and i like the
smell of the egg as i drink it i just
like to feel the do you know what i'm
going to call it
yes here we go
sour smelly iceberg sewer smelly ice
cream smelly ice cream well because it's
definitely sour it's a sour taste
and it's smelly super smelly and it
looks like a little iceberg there look
that could have sunk the titanic look at
that it's super
su sui sorry
yeah well we'll just call it a smelly
ace a humiliate smelly eyes smelly ice
yeah right there you go oh my god have
you guys had campari before smelly
iceberg yeah of course
there's a little bit of the bitterness
of a straight compound in there
i don't enjoy it it tastes like
chemicals there's a lot of there's a lot
of bitterness of not
a taste of this
and whoever can describe it best usually
like the pr person from the lord is
there and whoever can describe it best
gets a free shirt at every show
shirt wait hold on then i did a classic
chicago way too where you you do the
cheers like you're gonna drink it then
you don't drink and just watch the
outsiders drink it and see their pain
and then name it that's what you did
yeah yeah absolutely i on the other hand
so that she did and so what i'm trying
to say is congratulations you guys thank
you you got yourself a second one and
abs let me try it
yeah try it without the egg see if you
can come up with a second name but
that's not your invent your invention is
to smell the iceberg which is a smelly
iceberg please have them on friday at
your club and sean hold on smells of
aggie i will mention that and i'm sure
the people from the lord are going to
send you guys some more gifts after
seeing this yeah right and to work in
the word gifts are in quotes okay here
we go
don't eat any more
but i'm a lot t-shirt i would rock of
course i would take milo i would take a
look you know what it's like it's like
drinking perfume right mm-hmm
drinking perfume now that's beautiful
i mean because it's quite flowery now
there's an and
then there's something like as if they
put some poison in it
so it's slowly killing you yes after
you've drunk it's poison but you still
know you have like 45 minutes till you
have to do the anecdote you know yeah
like i got time
i want to rush to the hospital but we
got we should get there we should we
should pencil in there you're strong now
dom if there's if there's an egg on the
shirt do you have to make that shirt in
order to be able to wear it is it is how
far does this egg i'm i'm really
fascinated by it i'm okay with making
your own eggs making me a t-shirt with
an egg on it all right it's just um it's
it's when
eggs themselves are being made by people
i have to kind of know the process maybe
if i watch them in the kitchen i'm like
okay yeah i would have to say if there
was hold on
oh um
oh yeah oh wow yeah you're getting cocky
with it we're sure you're right it's on
your eyes after a while it's not that's
the thing with mallory it's not done
with you just because you're you're done
with it i would do that
yeah yeah you live with it
also i would i would describe a kind of
a fetid stench in the air now in this
room yeah of egg and and
[Music]
because i think like the next day you'd
be living with a well that's the thing
with it that's why it's so painful you
you you know you do it to get it out of
the way
and then you can just put it aside okay
it's done with you check it off the list
now let's get into the straight 18 you
know whiskey and cokes so wait a minute
i'm still not done with the egg thing
and you because i'm like cj it's kind of
right this is crazy
like i couldn't think of something that
is more hygienic than somebody boiling
you an egg because it's got a cover on
it no one's touched that yeah
no one in the world has touched the
inside of that egg no no so when you
peel it you are the first person you
ever have in fact
remember that sean when uh when you
order uh a smelly iceberg
the person places the egg in themself
don't have the barman do it no yeah do
you get it with the chevron
and then shell it you de-shell it the
shell goes into a bucket next to the bar
and that is used uh
for the nearby farms because it will
help the soil i love it
so why would that why would that bother
you the nearby chicago bar farms i don't
necessarily think there's any logic
associated with nervousness i think i've
uh i've ingested my mother's fear of
eggs and i don't think there's a huge
amount of uh logic with my mum's fear of
eggs either but there's a i'll continue
on william with this little blurb for a
second because that's an interesting
thing here says a handy map shows all
the bars and stores that sell milan
which at malor which is heavily tilted
towards chicago
you'll find places around the country
like washington dc and baltimore and one
barring in copenhagen but chicago is the
world capital of malor consumption but
that's only true because several
generations of chicagoans passed it down
we're a city of immense pride so we
embrace traditions even when they taste
terrible indeed one of chicago's
neighborhood bars
scoflar
has malor on tap
rumor has it the malort cocktail is
actually enjoyable colour me skeptical
says johnny clues yeah jesus wow it's
have you guys actually got
drunk on the law or have you just had it
as a shot and then jumped on no usually
very drunk when you have my lord too
it's not a starting off thing but i
would like to see that on tap that's
fascinating
i would imagine if you poured out it
would go back up inside the tap sometime
and terrified we have a
head back we have a friend
remember sam mecca i don't know if you
remember uh
the invention sam meckling made but you
know how like they have chilled yeager
yeah like those those mushrooms and bars
and chill yeager yeah he did like an
anti thing for that where it had melor
but it heated it up to 105 which he said
was the internal temperature of a wolf
and then he worked at a bar where he
would serve hot melory oh my god it was
disgusting
that's crazy that's what kind of started
the slogan thing itself right when sam
would write all these awful slogans for
and they sent him a seasoned assist and
they're like no i'm a fan
actually enjoying this that's why
there's a descriptive and then like they
wind up hiring them as a pr man like all
right tell them tell them everyone it's
like driving with a top down in gary
indiana you know that's what it was and
then they use it as their ad campaigns
that's what it says here yeah it says
chicago
will always be intertwined uh but it's
still really a cult drink jepsons
doesn't have the budget for print
advertising but cult followers have
created their own slogans and
commercials so people are making their
own commissions yes
yes i mean that's brilliant man i love
that it's like marmite we have a very um
polarizing spread
in england i don't know if you guys have
ever uh seen it called marmite
m-a-r-m-i-t
in britain i should say is the uh
the
end of the beer making uh industry uh
collects a whole bunch of spent or dead
probably yeast and it's like a
dark
brown almost black sludge
which at some point someone must have
dipped their finger in and tasted and
it's extremely salty very umami taste
they now sell it as marmite but the
advertising campaign for marmite is you
either love it or hate it i absolutely
love it yeah you love it too i love that
no yeah i thought that was our pudding
you're describing right no
savory spread but there are a lot of
people out there that can't be around if
you open up a jar in the kitchen they're
like oh marmite yes it's similar
now we normally give things scores uh
which uh you can be part of this if you
want to score it what what we give we
give it scores on its taste
it's what it looks like it's aesthetic
and how useful is it
in the house if you've got it and you
know you're using you're making
something or you're doing something
so as a taste dog oh it's going to be a
tough one this guys i mean i do not like
the taste at all
i would rather never taste that again
if i could hang on i'll taste it one
more time
yeah i think they they would accept a
load number on taste and they they would
take pride in it actually i don't want
to upset the people from the law
they lean into it as they say okay great
well i'm saying this based on a complete
uh ignorance of the the um beverage
itself but to me
it tastes dangerous
it does it
tastes like i've i've accidentally drink
a chemical that's ignorant
yeah that's also a great slogan ignorant
to beverage
itself yeah you know yeah just flat out
dangerous dangerous yes
dangerous absolutely give that score
dominance
i'll be generous and give it a 0.5 next
generation it's maybe the lowest score
yeah
and you can do decimal points
which i'll just show you right now cj
because which is actually below a one
it's below a one and uh i i think the
actual taste when you put it in your
mouth is all right it's a perfume a very
alcoholic taste but it's all right but
it leaves a
thing right from the middle of your
tongue
backwards yeah like i said this this
whole rankings i say it's incomplete
because it's not done with you yet no
there's still another 40 minutes for
this segment really marinate
absolutely yes i mean for taste alone
because of that little perfume at the at
the front there and i'll give a
but then it destroys itself i'll give it
a 3.2
like it's a self-destructing bot like
mission impossible yeah it's good it's
like it explodes within itself
yeah i've painted your tongue now with
[ __ ]
so just enjoy that for 45 minutes
and that's a good score to me um do you
want to give it a score cj for taste
yeah
taste i think it's i think i'll go with
five because you can go either you can
go it's a full on one way or full on the
other way so let's meet in the middle
and then whatever side you fall on
the lord will be there for you
can you remember enough to give her a
score
uh i can you know i think uh
this is so much not about the taste our
melor tradition i i'm going to give it
i'm going to go below dom and i'm i'm
going to give it a zero i think it's an
actual
zero
don't disagree with too many scores i
have to disagree with that i'd rather go
with the point five because there
because there is a taste to it
yeah it's like you can say it doesn't
have a taste i mean unless you have
covid right now well i think if it
didn't have a taste that would be a
higher score
it's a bad taste
it's an actively negative taste i'd
rather you go negative than zero yeah
can we can we go negative yeah yeah
all right there we go now aesthetics i
think it jumps up because i'm actually
quite charmed by the bottle yeah i think
the bottle is quite traditional
it's got the chicago flag on it kind of
slightly piratey vibes great bottle yeah
the name on it i thought the t-shirts
are good are the t-shirts just the
bottle kind of emblem you can get yeah
they have a lot of oh they they get
creative for sure but yeah let's we'll
get you a more uh bottle t-shirt i'm
gonna i'm gonna give it a i'm gonna give
it a 7.6 in terms of it as thick i mean
the drink itself is colorless
but the bottle is quite cool
william i agree it's got little things
uh
great description there it's got little
things
and you're right it's not color it's it
is colorless but it's it's trying to be
a brown licker is that it's just not
brown enough oh is it trying to yeah it
looks like it's red
yeah i think i think
i mean it's not amazing but yeah
now a 4.5 all right
then you got an airplane bottle and that
is that should be the only liquor
allowed on flights
you could have this and sit down though
yeah
oh god yeah
have yourself a smelly iceberg and we'll
wake up i'll wake you in st louis jesus
all right
what do you think aesthetic solid sex
pretty aesthetic i think you're right
nice nice tradition nice traditional
look to the bottle it's but it's lying
to you that's why i can't give it too
high of a score the aesthetic is it's a
nice traditional label i'm like like oh
so it deceives you like oh that looks
like a a drink like i've had before you
know and it's not really that's not at
all yeah yeah
all right uh sean any thoughts on the uh
aesthetic
i think it's great aesthetics i'm gonna
go nine um wow i love that it's like
yellow
and red and black almost like rat
poisoning or like a warning you know
if you go into any bar in chicago like
that bottle jumps out so much yeah you
never have to ask if no matter how many
bottles they have behind you can tell
within three seconds if they serve them
alort because that bottle just pops out
due to its coloring great design so i'm
gonna say a nine wow
yeah i like it how useful is it
can you add it like would if you
do you think we're going to see it in
chef programs you know like um
kitchen nightmare and stuff right
somebody's made like a beef thing and
they do a flambe with melon
yeah it's definitely great
for destruction i mean it doesn't have
to be just for
creating no it's not cuisines or
anything like that yeah i don't think
it's real useful as an ingredient okay
but right it's very useful as a bonding
experience in chicago like a lot of
people like that's like your first
official chicago memory
was like you moved to the city and
there's two things that happened that
make you a chicago and you get your car
towed and you do a shot of melody you
know
and so i think like i consider it like a
10 on usefulness because i think it's
like part of this like
tribal you join our group type thing
yeah i mean if it's bringing together a
society of people that's extremely
useful
uh you wouldn't put it i don't think
you'd do like a milot and tonic or a
milan soda is that what people might do
oh no it's just a show yeah i think you
just have to do the it's almost always
just a shot there must be something
there's someone listening who's like
sealant what's everybody talking about i
love my lore oh yeah oh absolutely
there's people who love it and then you
don't know like
really or if they're just really playing
that
character just to be arbitrary you know
but then nobody goes in and says i have
three ice cubes and a nice tonic water
and i'm a lot
i mean
then sometimes you you hear people like
that and then you find out other details
like i heard one guy like that and then
like i i like he keeps excusing himself
and then i realized like this guy smokes
like 5000 cigarettes a day so this is
probably the only thing he can taste you
know
that can cut through even tar it'll cut
through
on your tongue
stole on my tongue
yeah yeah it's a weird kind of uh
lingering taste right and you're not i
don't think you're adding this to
cakes or pies no it's more for your
decks like the seal like waterproof
things or something like that you know
it's more of an outdoor right
stripping exactly
well i uh sean i absolutely love that
thing that you said that it is useful
because
it can bring together maybe people on
their first freshers week at university
people coming together as a bonding
experience that makes it very useful i'm
going to pump up the scores in terms of
that so i'm going to give it
i'll give it a 5.2 i i agree i think
things like that in a city are really
important when people come to glasgow as
always you know it's fish and chips and
iron brew and right and tenants lager
and a good whiskey that's good with
things that you you really so i'm going
to give it a high one because of that
nice i'm going to give it a 7.5 wow
that's great yeah that's fantastic what
was yourself cj is it useful oh that's
usefulness i'll say 9.9 just because uh
because it's something that no one
agrees on and that's something we still
need in society just you know i love
that creative disagreement like
especially at a bar you know a good
old-fashioned discussion that can't be
settled by google or something you know
just all back and forth and pain and
different opinions
pain and joy and tears and eggs and you
know and yeah and it all comes into it
pain and joy tears and eggs i got a spit
today in chicago red red hot chili
[Laughter]
and
pepper
uh did you give it a score i know you
said it was useful but i don't think you
can give it to school
i i'm gonna go ten i'm gonna go ten wow
high scores a minus three to ten right
big range
that's what that's what i'm saying about
this malaria you carry so many different
opinions on it yes you know well i
wonder if my dad would like it because
my dad enjoys every so often at the
campari and soda and there's a little
bit of that bitterness yeah
yeah
so don't make that all right good well
smash in one night yeah absolutely that
was great you know on billion dollar
world we've said this to people um since
we started doing it it doesn't always
have to be something
objectively great like a you know apple
pie or you know something super yummy we
just want interesting stuff and that was
certainly one of the more interesting
yeah
certainly it was not delicious
no a fascinating beverage because people
will drink that like tonight in chicago
people are getting that down they
absolutely it will be yeah sure it's
made me feel kind of weird okay well
should we talk about that yeah remember
remember there was a time when you
remember that's what i'm saying remember
it was a time when you liked it way back
i mean it came out of the eyes and now
it's like now it's kind of down by the
knees it gets you know it's a weird
place now yeah it's uh well what pass
through do you think cj it passes
through kind of uh
respiratory kind of like yeah like kind
of coverage kind of like through like
not not actually it's inside and outside
the system but just kind of osmosis
it'll cut little patches i'm looking
forward to it
and me anymore right now
you've had a rough go i think it's
recently because you i think you're the
bad oyster physically it'll be out of
here but spiritually it'll always be a
part of what would be about yeah of
course well before we let you guys go
tell us a little bit more about your
your podcast and what would what would
bring people to
listening to your podcast and also where
anyone can check you guys out on a
weekly basis
sure absolutely well the blackout
diaries podcast which comes out every
tuesday our third episode like we said
it's a lot of great stories that come
from a live show from normal people and
stand-up comics hilarious drunken
stories don't not always have to be
drunken but it helps yeah what i mean
like uh we did a
search party episode the other day where
a guy got so drunk he uh
he was missing there was a search party
for him and then he woke up and joined
his own search party looking for himself
did he defend himself they found himself
at the bar lately okay then
things of that nature well check that
out the blackout diaries wherever you
get your podcasts and then that sounds
fun
you do a weekly live show of the
blackout diaries and does that become
the podcast yeah every friday at a place
called the lincoln lodge uh at 10 p.m
and uh yeah come by check that out we
are sponsored by milord so if you saw
this podcast and you're intrigued by
melor but i haven't tried it yet uh come
to the blackout diaries and try it out
what's it called the lincoln what the
lincoln lodge it's a comedy theater uh
on the north side of chicago longest
running independent comedy show in
america ran by wow englishman mark geary
actually well
cause billy and i were recently in
chicago and if we didn't know about it
we could have taken a little journey
and lincoln lodge is the only place uh
in the world where you can get a smelly
iceberg yes that is true enjoy it isn't
100 true absolutely gentlemen it's been
fantastic having you on thanks a lot for
uh recommending yourself and we look
forward to it thank you here in the uh
the blackout diaries what a great thank
you for a podcast thank you darren billy
thank you very much
that was fantastic that was probably
i think the toughest thing that i've
certainly done on billion dominate the
world so far drinking that
was still with me well like you said
that it's the taste mixed with the after
kind of feelings i i i barely had any
and i can feel it in my solar plexus i
had a lot and that mine had an egg in it
what are you doing well i didn't mean
the egg to go and what did you told the
story about the tapas and you put that
on a plate yeah so i thought well maybe
if you put an egg on it it would be the
same but the egg
egg can change shape like a rack and
down a drain pipe and it went through
your fingers it slipped them yeah and
then it became it became very slippery
and then i drank it and i was oh an eggy
drink yeah sitting with me it's sitting
dumb it's lovely to have cj and sean on
that sounds like a great show yeah that
would be great we've very funny we've
all had nights out um even if you've not
been drinking where you kind of think
whoa that was an adventurous night uh
we've all been there and like cj said to
us after we finished podcast there's no
shame associated with that show i think
more than anything else what they're
trying to say is we've all been there
does it
we've all had to shut off the side of a
canoe at some point yeah we've all been
there it's fine so uh check out
their show
uh we've run out of time but let's tell
people a few things about what's going
on
well we've got the art thing what are we
calling that again
fanart the fanart episode where we're
going to look at people's art fan art
fanart fanat and that's going to be
sometime around the 5th of september
labor day here in america and if you if
you've made anything that's sort of
lauder rings or billion dom or
friendship onion please send it our way
and we'll open it up on that episode
that will be great we'll open it up on
the show and hopefully we'll find places
on the wall where we can put it and it
will live permanently on the um
the friendship on your wall you can also
rate review and subscribe to our podcast
if you subscribe to the podcast but
you've not rated or reviewed it give us
a little five star rating give us a
little one sentence review it super
helps us continue to make this show you
can leave questions comments and
concerns at the french bunion at youtube
and you can watch us there and you can
also leave a voice
mail at
speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion or
you can send us emails to the friendship
onion at cassmedia.com you can also get
our merchandise merch they call it at
the
friendshiponionpodcast.com yes and if
you'd like to send in suggestions for
things for billy and i to eat or drink
on billion don't meet the world remember
it doesn't need to be
amazingly pleasant food it can be just
interesting food see if you can find
something that we can actually find in
the united states unfortunately people
have given us great suggestions from
around the world but it's stuff that you
can't get into the united states so
hopefully something that we can find
here in california and we will see you
guys next week on the friendship onion
turtles
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your oyster baby you're my pearl